is the New York Times giving readers bad
info about Israel its front page reads
Israel strike kills hundreds in hospital
Palestinians say that's what they say
but is it true nope according to us
intelligence the Palestinian Hospital
explosion was caused by rocket fire not
from Israel but from Palestinian Islamic
Jihad a Palestinian terrorist group that
hit the hospital by mistake that image
of an obliterated building on the Times
front page wasn't actually the hospital
which is really unclear unless you look
very closely casualty estimates have not
been confirmed either now with this new
info the times had to rewrite its
headlines over and over again mainstream
media ought to be more careful because
they really jumped the gun on this story
it's important to get the facts right no
matter which side looks bad because of
them